everyone loves a good sale and with
online shopping everything is that much
easier because time and place will never
be an obstacle you can shop 24 7 there's
so much variety to choose from and it
all gets delivered straight to your
doorstep so while you're checking off
their shopping list for Black Friday
you may also treat yourself
am I right
see treating yourself is very very
important like my mama always says ciao
you better take care of yourself before
you take care of others she doesn't
sound like that at all she's actually
much much scarier
hi Mom and just by taking a few minutes
in a day to invest in your own
well-being can drastically boost your
cognitive physical and emotional health
just a little TLC can do wonders on your
outlook
yeah I kind of ran out of cucumbers but
uh you know Tomatoes it's a it's a new
thing I'm trying out now to give you
some information we have created a
collection of self-care Essentials on
amazon.sg that you can get for yourself
or for your loved ones these products
are going to cover a wide range of
self-care needs we're talking about
gadgets Fitness Beauty and even
something for your kitchen even
groceries and if you're planning to grab
any of these items be sure to check out
the link in the description box below so
let's check it out
we got a lot of stuff but
let's start off with this
okay now if you're looking for a
complete salon blowout
this is going to do everything for you
this is the play Vogue One Step hair
dryer it's a hair color a hair
straightener a blow dryer and a comb
check it out premium
it's copper plated you got nice charcoal
bristles here honestly for its size I
would expect something a lot heavier now
the cool thing is that you have a few
different settings you got a cool you
got your heart and you got your hot plus
these bristles on top of the actual hair
straightener has negative ions built
into it so it actually grips on when
you're gonna straighten your hair on top
of that the tip is completely cool so
with people with long hair if you're
gonna like brush it at least you know
you can hold the tip as well without
scalding your fingers and yes this is
for myself because
look guys this looks as if a bird came
into my hair made a nest and never left
then I hear chopping
somewhere oh wow
but before that I I got a I gotta prep
my hair so the trick here is that you
want to have damp hair now you don't
want it soaking wet
but just want it damp enough and just
gotta remove some of the excess water
because if you don't do that you're just
gonna end up damaging your hair
and I'm really that damaged
he got some natural calls here
if you're going to straighten it and
hopefully
I don't look
weird say
so
it was nothing
[Applause]
with this hairbrush you don't have to
juggle between a hair dryer and a hair
streak and it just does everything right
and it actually does everything in
double the time
so you're really the goal just like that
and because of the copper plates and the
negative ions it creates 40 percent less
frizz how do I look man fine perfect
dude it's time for date night
this product's got a lot of brownie
points on the Amazon website scoring at
4.2 out of 5 stars and this is one of
our top picks under seventy dollars so
yeah
job play Vogue on to the next one aha
this is going to be great
if you want to strive for radiant skin
maybe perhaps look even younger
then you should get one of these this is
the fancy exfoliating cleansing brush I
myself I don't really use an exfoliator
brush in fact this is probably my first
time using it now it comes with its own
travel case which is very Epic
so let's fry it open
and you've got your exfoliating brush
okay very nice soft bristles
we've got another brush for more deeper
cleansing and you've got a nice silicone
brush oh pops out right there for
sensitive skin all right now the fancy
exfoliating cleansing brush comes under
50 and it has over 9 000.
9 000 reviews
coming out at 4.3 out of 5 Stars so one
more thing about the fancy exfoliating
cleansing brush is that it's ipx6
waterproof let's say you can use this in
the shower no problems at all turn on
and see
just do your makeup routine makeup
routine D makeuping routine is that what
I call it cleansing routine geez n click
one more time high speed
all right so as you can see across the
board we have a few goodies over here
these are local Brand Products here in
Singapore if you're a fan of coffee
like myself then you guys gotta try out
hook coffee all right they got a variety
of flavors in fact we have all gray and
sweet bunchen which is kind of like a
quino bueno-esque flavor coffee profile
now Xeno is the coffee expert kind of
coffee Corner Joe here so I'm assuming
we just need to do this open balls oh it
splits open like that oh okay
oh I didn't see that oh I kind of want
to get the thing to like a hook on
that's what the thing is for oh no
wonder
it's called hook coffee
open up the top yeah like real quick now
all you need is some love and 150 ml of
hot water there's a bunch of different
flavors from Earl Gray to yes Kindle
Bueno even chocolate chip and even
fruity ones like sparkling grape soda
and mango pudding can you imagine coffee
cheers guys
can you smell the Kindle buenos
notes of it I wouldn't say it's like
strong like you won't expect going to a
candy store and smelling chocolate kind
of thing but
foreign
y day kind of coffee and I'm saying so
the cool thing about hook coffee is that
they're delivered within a week of
roasting so you're gonna get the
freshest Brew all right you you will
notice that sometimes coffee loses the
the coffee-ness if you will this however
solid
all right next is this this is
handball from a brand called jomingo
it's a local brand here in Singapore and
it's completely plant-based natural
resources completely vegan as well and
essentially it's just hand balm and you
know it's meant to moisturize
plotting like an evil
cater
um
and it's supposed to keep your hands
moisturized the skin moisturized now
it's made and tested for people living
in Singapore because of the tropical
climate tropical heat and they're going
to end up with a lot of dryness your
skin stays moisturized even after
frequent washing so good
look how shiny that is
Rosemary and mint no his name is Pogo
isn't he cute yes and you're probably
familiar with him because he stars in an
animation called oddbots and yeah
they're just super huggable super
cuddles super cuddles
they're just gonna bring in love and
enjoyment so whether it's an infant
whether it's a toddler whether it's an
adult he's just gonna enjoy them so yeah
as you can see there is a lot of things
happening on the table and that's
because I want to show you this this is
the Jin Vu Smart Wi-Fi power strip so
long are the days where you have to
manually switch on and off
a plug and I got the latest 4th gen Echo
dot right here
I'm going to show you how the magic
happens
Alexa
Turn on Ninja Turtles
okay
boom
so not only can you control it remotely
via the app it's also voice controlled
via Alexa and Google Assistant
now on top of all that
check this out
Alexa
turn off Raphael
okay
Alexa turn off splinter
you can control
the switches individually how cool is
that this is like something I've been
waiting for for so long by the way
you see the art reactor Gauntlet and
this clock
so
check out the link man that's all yeah
let's talk about one of my favorites
this is the Ace Fast three in one
wireless charging station now this is
catered to iOS devices where they have
the iPhone 12 iPhone 13 airpods Apple
watch that supports the wireless
charging feature
this is gonna get it done it's an
all-in-one solution So airpods Pro
iPhone 13 snap
and
if I turn it around you've got yourself
the Apple watch
now why I love this is simply because it
just declutters everything right you
don't need three cables or three
Chargers to Simply charge all three
devices more importantly it supports up
to 15 watts of fast charging so it's
gonna get everything charged in no time
at all this is for all you party animals
out there this is the JBL charge 5. this
is also Amazon's Choice a little bit
more premium costing under 250 dollars
and of course why we're recommending
this is because it's one of the best
sounding portable Bluetooth speaker
systems we've ever tested on top of that
hey it duels as a very handy power bank
to keep your devices charged and keep
the party going all night long
speaking about partying all night long
this has up to 20 hours of playback time
on top of that hey water spilled drinks
rain sand
this thing is IP67 waterproof and dust
proof so you can literally take this
anywhere and it's so loud in fact let me
test it real quick
[Music]
hey ABC
50 volume let's turn it up to a hundred
so it's crazy so yes small compact and
it can fill the whole room in fact you
can bring this Outdoors too
see I told you it works great outdoors
and what better way
than to work out
I kind of I did two there
I'm very good at this
but oh oh they're jumping
it's gonna get you a good cardio workout
now I have to say it is essential to
take care of your health and exercise is
a great way what I have here is the 10
gram smart jump rope
it's a smart rope just smarter now with
the smart Rope app which supports Apple
health and Google Fitness you are able
to just track everything from your
calories it's gonna count how many jumps
you make there's even an interval
function so you can have a high
intensity workout and you also have a
global leaderboard so if you score
really really good points on this
you're going to show people who's boss
oh
I think I pulled a cramp uh Xeno told me
to stretch it out we should stretch
before I've got something even better
this is the rainfall massage gun and
instead of using a foam roller or you
know simply stretching
uh you're gonna take less effort
to do the same exact function ah yeah
oh it's a great way to give yourself a
massage and on top of that
it's going to improve circulation and
with improved circulation you're gonna
heal a lot faster so after an intense
workout if you have any muscle soreness
this is going to help you a lot
yeah it's got 5 000 reviews and it's got
4.7 out of 5 stars
so this bad boy
it's going to help you so much
and this works
there you go so after that heavy workout
you gotta treat yourself right and what
better way than to make yourself a
healthy uh meal yeah
okay this is the Ninja foodie Dual Zone
airfryer that's right that's not have
one basket but it has two independent
baskets that can hold up to 3.8 liters
of food each this is something I've
never seen before and it's supposedly
the first in the world to have this two
baskets together it's gonna be glorious
yes and some of you might be asking oh
Zaki but you know what if my fries come
out in eight minutes and then my steaks
come out at 15 minutes wanna get cold no
with the sync function over here
it will actually keep the food warm and
both of them will be out at the same
time with its smart sync function
how cool is that
I'm getting so heavy
hungry so we got our hands washed
we're gonna turn this bad boy on oh I
didn't even plug it in what am I doing
what am I doing
I'm gonna get a buns nice and toasty in
fact these buttons you see how nice and
Supple they are the mince meat all the
spices that went into it the onion
powder the garlic powder salt pepper the
french fries all of these came from
Amazon Fresh
and
best part about it all is that it came
within two hours same day delivery
Amazon Prime membership y'all
maximum freshness is all we're gonna get
today
that's fake patties
there we go
Lord help Mercy
ah got a buns in I'm gonna wash my hands
once again and while the patties are
being cooked we're gonna toast two buns
and on top of that we're gonna load up
some fries so hopefully it works okay
Daniel we've done the second batch of
buns we're gonna load in some fries oh
that's a bit too much we're gonna set
this to the max crisps all right now
let's do the burgers first and uh okay
uh the cheese did not stay on look at
that juicy burger
all right now it's time to bathe this
boys
with the fries Max crisp look at that
nice and golden brown you get it you hit
it you see that it's so good
no you know you know why I know
this is gonna taste good
it's not only because
you know kind of did it by myself but
because I got this cookbook man
from Amazon
the airfryer Perfection from crispy
fries and juicy sticks to perfect
vegetables what to cook and how to get
the best results when you flip over to
page 81 juicy well done cheeseburgers
that's that recipe
put that on a cracker
oh Lord look at that ready ready for a
close-up three two one
[Music]
you sit here
you grab your other piece
[Music]
and fried burger right who would have
known
so this concludes our video we hope you
guys enjoyed it and if you're planning
to pick any of these items for
yourselves do check out the link below
so with that this is Zaki signing off
happy shopping whoa